we have an excellent show I friends I
cannot stress enough the importance of
racking up those whammies for the bonus
round you are going to need plenty of
whammies
in the bonus round what is what is that
what is it what is this guy who are you
testing testing one two three stand
stand can you hear me hello
goddamnit is there anybody in the mouth
no no sir there is no stand here can I
help you mother is that you
no no I'm not your mother on the host of
the show no sir I'm the host
three two one of America's favorite game
show fill in the blanks
[Music]
[Applause]
Zion read Newport just like the
cigarettes so popular with the urban
crowd sorry I'm sorry you're in the
wrong studio you're in the wrong studio
that was a great game show they shot
that on the CBS la tapa stick
Annie what's going on you know I I think
I know who this guy is he's sort of
famous here at Warner Brothers he's that
leftover game show host who wandered
who's wandered around a lot since his
show was canceled like 30 years whoever
guesses the secret word will get 100
points but if the Weeble lands on the
red X well look out okay any I don't
know this is kind of sad what do we do
what do we do now most of the time they
just let him go he's harmless yeah
Miguel from Long Beach how long have you
been a podiatrist seven weeks survey
says
tough break Miguel knock hey his name's
Miguel and would give me a favor would
you please leave my audience alone seven
weeks is just incorrect Luis Lee
Fernando coming all the way from Santa
Fe where I understand you trained Birds
sure
Leslee you just have a secret
[Music]
[Applause]
two contestants will enter and both will
leave but one of them will have won the
showdown between our two returning
champions and their names are Andy
Randi and Conan Denise okay no it's not
Denise well here we go one of my
favorite desserts is milk and cookies so
I'm sorry the correct answer is scotch
that's minus one for Denise ouch
sometimes when I can't sleep I'll fix
myself a nice warm bowl of scotch it's a
year supply of Lee genes go down to the
roller skating rink or the local rodeo
and flash a look that says I'm ready for
free or extramarital sex well today do
they still make Li Jie's yeah survey
says yes they do
and that means it's time to appalled
no three read Newport can you hear me
that time it was definitely mother
that's what there's just stop read
stopping Sabo never stop that's my motto
at least it was until my most recent
stroke okay just take a break
read take a break whoa bring that bow
[Music]
folks it's time to tickle the - no no
we're not gonna we're not gonna tickle
the turkey read your game show it was
canceled a long long time ago it's okay
it's time to stop you can rest now
all right you can just rest
well you know uh maybe it is time to
pack up my things and move down south
all the way to the bonus yes that's
right Reid you made it all the way to
the bonus round
yeah graduation are you yes I cannot
hear anything I cannot see anything
and as a matter of fact you came well
I'm having a difficult time breathing it
all right yeah what's our Andy Daly
everybody
[Applause]